good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning trust happy Monday it is an
hour earlier the sun is shining even
brighter vanish oh my god that's what it
was this morning I was sitting at my
vanity the Sun was shining on my face in
a way that was making it hard for me to
do my makeup and I was like what is
going on I sit here every day at this
time and this never happened not the
study light savings y'all daylight's nay
chests so we got an hour didn't feel it
at all I mean I'm really excited I
wasn't I didn't leave my house really
all day yesterday so I don't really get
to see what it was like a five o'clock
being dark um yes you didn't see
Barney's we did an amazing vlog and we
did feel that it was earlier because we
were having lunch dinner at 5:45 and we
were like oh my god it's only 5:45 but
really it's 6:40 I watched argh I walked
home in the drum yes
so wouldn't notice it anyways which is a
great segue into the fact that we did a
vlog yesterday for our patreon channel
critically-acclaimed and it was so fun
we had so much fun doing it we had
talked about it on the show as you know
Barney's is going out of business
claudia has announced a dollar gift card
it's really hard to find anything to buy
at Barney's but we took you on the
journey with us and it was actually a
great success as you can see our new
shoes our new shoes today I'm really
excited about it
the entire experience was very
eye-opening for me and just really
cemented the beliefs I had about
Barney's like the story very well should
be going out of business yeah and if you
watch our vlog like and you don't live
in New York and you've never been to
Barney's where you don't understand why
I would be going out of business and why
we might be happy about that just watch
the vlog all your questions will be
answered patreon.com slash the morning
toast I'm proud of a lot of the BTS work
actually I shouldn't say BTS oh we're
out of a lot of the Highness Singh's
work that I've done from patreon um but
folks are saying that this is the best
episode I've ever done which they are
saying that it's so crazy because I
didn't I didn't know it's just like your
natural skills getting better and better
so like you don't even think that it's
your best work because you're just doing
like your regular work but your regular
work is now your best work because
you've been working so much yeah and I'm
just getting quicker and quicker like my
turnaround time was like two hours
yesterday super fast yeah I was just
really excited about it so once you
watch that if you're still looking for
content our new TNN show day tonight
with Raven and Adam officially launched
today their first episode is up it's
called how to find a good guy or girl so
it's standing advice for men women so
all the single toasters go check it out
it's on Spotify and iTunes they're so
cute Ravens voice like you
fall asleep - it's perfect for podcast
love her voice their podcast is great
cuz it has so much advice but it's also
like such a wonderful window into their
relationship and they're so cute with
each other I was listening on my way to
work this morning and I was just like
smiling what a great way to start your
diet maybe that's how people feel about
the toast but I don't have a toast to
listen to every day by the way okay
that's so funny that you said that
because me and Marco were in Toronto
this weekend and I got home and I was
showing been like pictures and videos
and they showed him a picture that there
was like a huge pregame like they said
Oh like almost 125 people showed I saw
posted it to my story like the cult was
on fire on I was super cozy Melania
showed bed and he was like that's so fun
like you ever wish you were a toaster
and I'm like yeah yeah no I wish I was a
toaster when we're at cam toast like I
wish I could just be in front of it and
not be a coordinator totally you've been
getting so many like increase about camp
toast because it's holiday season people
wanna buy tickets the tickets will be up
in time for holiday season they'll be up
in the beginning of December so stay
tuned but it'll be pretty much same
procedure as last year a pre-sale at
patreon.com session morning toast it's
gonna be about the same size as last
year so I expect it's gonna sell out
quickly so much for a great gift to gird
your loins my friends good your
mother-fucking Lloyd but we also were
gonna have so many wonderful gifts gift
options at our merch store for holidays
so stay tuned for that I'm so [ __ ]
excited you guys like tis the
[ __ ] season and I we just woke
up one day and it was winter like I'm
wearing a fur coat that's freezing I
never even went from like - there was no
parka steez and I don't know fall there
was no fall we went from summer to
winter and even though fall is nice um
the sooner winter comes the better I
like I just really love I love the cold
obviously because I'm just like a big
fat woman who like is always sweating
and like roaming outside and like
feeling you know my nipples get hard
really gets me all excited but also it's
like the camaraderie and it's a spirit
of winter is also what really attracts
me to it it's the the the holiday cheer
you know there's so much cheer so much
cheery vibes we should change the name
to the morning cheer hey counselor
snitch hi you're coming over there good
how's the strep throat she's good she's
um she's ashamed yeah and you're
grateful that your employer's they let
you have the days off cuz it I am very
grateful to my employers into modern
medicine must be so nice to have such
you know nice employers yeah must be so
nice well we missed you but we're happy
to have you back we did miss you Margo
killed it in Toronto she want to give me
a shout out like Toronto's our place
like I think our toe
these towns are New York and Toronto
like I'm not gonna lie in Toronto at
loss teens biggest podcast Massachusetts
yeah that's true they need to redo that
study by the way I know when it's a
toaster whose cut research company did a
study and like please leave just a study
and if it's fine if you find out that
we're not the number one publishing just
don't publish it yeah okay so like I am
to Toronto or like Mariah but Celine
Dion is too much it's giving him what
leave it Jake leave it please
so yes Toronto is just it for us like we
can move there except the whole customs
thing like I just it was too too
treacherous but once you live there
nobody we come visit family in the
States we have to work in the States and
every time we fly home we have to
[ __ ] go through we have to be like in
the States and you have to call it in
the so lame right fed stuff
so Charlie good show we got a bunch of
shows coming out most summer sold out
but there are still tickets left to
Turning Stone turn those stones y'all
and Rona Ontario wrong Rama
Ontario to casino shows which I potato
potato the but the families coming to
both of them because we love a casino
weekend we are turning shown in Verona
New York and then Rama Casino and Rama
Ontario tickets are available girls no
job calm there are also still very few
two seats left to Terry Tarrytown and
Kansas City and Atlantic City New Jersey
and Englewood New Jersey so just head
over to girls no job calm it has all
your ticketing needs we had such a good
show in Toronto like the show is just
I'm said that the tour's ending because
like I'm at my peak now like I'm just
I'm really I know what I'm good at and I
know what I'm mad at and I'm better you
know all things athleticism
I'm bad at you know my style isn't like
you know I'm know Jackie yeah I think
you're a style icon says okay this is
boots
thank you those boots are on the cutting
edge my friend I have not seen one other
person where I've never seen them before
neither but now you're gonna see them
everywhere my show is great like I don't
think I could always say that you know
like women beginning in the comedy clubs
like it was all right you know but after
the show in Toronto I'm just full of
confidence you know I'm she was [ __ ]
great and you guys should come see it
that's so exciting I mean I've seen it
and so I can attest to that and it's
just gonna be a great rest of the year
banging out shows banging out toes
banging out merch we have summit we have
camp toast coming up we're really
becoming a business where it's a q4 is
so heavy y'all
like you for is it and that's how people
feel like at regular workplaces it's
like youth like the summer is pretty
quiet q4 it's like all hands on deck
we're having up and then we all go on
vacation and then January is quiet but
like you guys q4 for the toasters is
gonna be a very exciting quarter first
so many different reasons and so just
stay tuned things you know some things
you don't know and it's gonna be great
I'm very excited gonna be incredible as
American Canberra would say do you think
so I think it's time honestly no but I
don't know why it wouldn't be time we
have a lot to recap we're gonna talk
about the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians episode that aired last
night the premiere of Real Housewives of
Atlanta I have many many many thoughts
and I can't believe I slept on the
franchise for so long i'm like so
disappointed in myself but it's it's
here and I'm here and I'm excited about
it I'm happy for you and I'm glad that
you'll be happy for those who watch I
haven't gotten around to it it's so good
you have to like you can't be sleeping
on Atlanta no but like it's getting
harder and harder for me to watch TV
because I just like watch like watching
like stupid [ __ ] on my phone and right
anyway and like I just make a patreon
video and then I watch it ten times and
I go to sleep
totally oh so now we're coming on a week
where we now have Atlanta Dallas OC and
New Jersey premieres this week yeah four
franchises like I don't know how I'm
gonna survive in one in Morocco like I
got to get two episodes on my computer
or something I cannot believe you're
going to Morocco I know I know I'm very
excited there's gonna be so crazy you
guys I mean I would say we have
Nashville CMA Awards we're going on
vacation to Utah which is gonna be a
dream which we're really taking up my
birthday in two days Wow oh my god I am
just so evolved that I don't keep
talking about it but like my birthday's
in two days we're turning 27 Wow and a
prime number
we're gonna turn those stones yeah
that's what we're gonna turn those
mother but it's not as I remember oh
yeah it's not it's usable by nine and
desaad yeah yeah divisible by snitch and
speech agree well okay college grad Wow
now that we've been chained we did so
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite of
your morning cheer okay it's time but I
have to share an amazing update from one
of our sponsors because we spoke about
this a little while ago about embark the
dog DNA test which is just [ __ ]
genius and I told you guys that I swab
Theo's cheek and I sent in the results
well I got them back even more
little song about it and but we'll get
to that okay who wants to know Theo's
results I just want to say by them
swabbing his cheek me swabbing his cheek
they could guess his weight and they
nailed it on the head twenty-one pounds
how great a big boy yes maybe like
eighteen then I think the most shocking
thing that came out of this was Theo's
wolf enos statistic you guys so Meow's
wealthiness most dogs have a wolf inna
score of 1% or less because dogs are
descended from wolves as we know from
that commercial we find populations and
grooms with higher scores of 2% of 2% to
4% occasionally and unique dogs with
scores of 5% or above Theo is a 3% wolf
enos he is an above average dog he's
such a wolf like that makes so much time
it's not a measure of he always did
relate to Jacob from Twilight so true
and you know he always he does have a
middle part so it makes some sense
they say he's born in Dallas you know
what his genetic ages his human age he's
my age 27 7 you both are 27 years old
Tracy that because I thought we were
siblings because we look like but we're
actually twins right Holly we're like
twins how crazy is that I can't believe
he's 27 he doesn't act like it and by
the way holiday season this is actually
a great gift to get for like a psychotic
dog mom like myself I feel like so much
closer to Theo now that I know like all
of his genetic you know makeups ya know
it's you have to know about your dog you
really do and we know a lot about Theo
obviously it says in there that he is a
doctor and he's a political refugee and
he's a precious gem of a man yeah that's
sometimes something that people can't
quantify I mean when a scientist tells
you that it like really cements it for
you yeah so he just took a DNA test
turns out he's a hundred percent Russian
even when he's leading countries yeah
he's got dog problems that's a copy in
him
bling-bling man he's awesome that's a
doctor in could I had an MD medicine Oh
helped you with your welfare just a
little that you still hold him down and
now they're holding me back and that's
the sound of him not barking you back
wow I'm so impressed that's what I was
working on in LA she'll the 'mark dog
DNA 10 bark if any of our other sponsors
won't fold on sync oh yeah we charge
extra the embark talk DNA test kit is
the most comprehensive kit on the market
looking at over 250 breeds and 170
genetic health conditions to help you
best care for your pup embark is the
only research grade dog DNA test
kid on the market they analyzed a
hundred times more genetic information
than any other DNA test on the market
this means that their scientists look at
over 200,000 genetic makers and can make
scientific discoveries that help all
dogs have longer healthier lives it's
super easy to get started and they're
the only company with stellar customer
service and vets and veterinary genetics
on staff to talk you through your
results it's the best in class dog DNA
tests and number one highest rated by
customers and developed by PhDs and
veterinarians for your dogs embark has
an exclusive holiday offer because like
we said this is a great gift for a
psycho dog mom that you know even not so
psycho or a psycho dog and right psycho
dog ant in your life get a man embark it
has an exclusive holiday offer that you
can't get anywhere else
go to embark vet dot-com now use the
promo code toast to save 15% off your
dog DNA test kit visit embark vet calm
and use promo code toast to save again
that's EMBA RK v ET comm use the promo
code toes to save 15% off you know you
really can't put a price on you know
knowing your dog's genetic makeup you
like it's really crazy that it meet live
in a time where you can know your jobs
tremendous up and we should all be
taking advantage of that a gird a gird
ok someone said I BBE big birthday
energy you got BB for sure sir I had a
big booby energy Oh same okay are you
ready for the stories because honestly
they're super Kardashian heavy and
there's really no other people that I
want to be talking about like anymore at
so [ __ ] sure I just I will talk about
anything that they do I'm here for that
okay but the first story is the biggest
one we posted about it up to morning
toast on Friday but we haven't done to
show sins Rob Kardashian's steps out for
Kendall Jenner's Halloween birthday
party and he lays a hand on Stassi okay
he looked like he put his hand
ya know meet her know he like touched
spicy baby okay
so everyone was out at the kendall
Jenner Halloween party and then like a
day later we saw one or two pictures of
Rob Kardashian so it was like really
special that he was there and being
photographed because I don't think he
really goes anywhere and if he does he's
certainly not being photographed and by
the why don't you pictures that I saw I
saw a pretty chiseled jawline so
methinks he might be getting into shape
yeah he's getting into shape he's
healing good enough to take one to go
out and to to take pictures Kylie posted
a picture of she got permission
she got permission
it was like a club photo and it seemed
like they all had a great time and like
I can't state enough how this era of
Kardashian is just incredible
but now adding Rob to the mix and now
there's like rumors and I don't believe
them but I I want to that Robins saucy
baby like I might be there might be some
sparks there well there was a picture of
them yeah but I did hear that that
picture was actually just a still from a
video of him helping her get in the car
like nothing crazy
no but wing but look at the picture it's
like so [ __ ] tender but also it's
like why get in the car together you
know there's more this is aircrew it's I
understand why they're getting in the
car together they're like their crew
they're going from one place to the next
like they you share a car and he was
being a gentleman like helping her get
into the car bodycon dress when you look
at the picture there's just like so much
tenderness there and I love this for
them like I think that it's just like
how Kylie starts with Sophia who is you
know the step mom to all of her nephew
see dresses like Stassi should be dating
wrong you know this is like further
incestual like and it's just so weird
because like you would think maybe this
is something that Kylie doesn't like
like maybe she was scarred by Jordan
like literally kissing her sisters like
man on the lips like it just sometimes
it's like a little too close for comfort
but at the same time like Kylie is so
invested in her friendships and in her
family and that loyalty is something she
relies on so heavily so like actually
this makes a lot of sense yeah maybe if
like Tristan and Chloe had fully broken
up it was two years later like Kylie
would have been Doris Jordan and Kristen
but it's kind of like if Jordan had
started dating French Montana no one
would have cared no that's so true I was
actually watching all the episodes of
Kardashians yesterday the whole Jordan
saga again and like it's even crazier
when you watch it with hindsight because
it's just so crazy we were so in the
weeds yeah and it's just wild um and I
really hope that this relationship works
out for Stassi maybe in Rob Kardashian
cousin like maybe she'll stop vlogging
because her vlogs are terrible yeah no I
just like I love when friends become
family and I feel like it's such a great
example has been made with Sophia yeah
and I just the more the more the merrier
yeah but there is a risk always like you
know that it doesn't work out or like
things end badly and then it's like you
become you stay with a friend or like
family first
there there's weirdness but at the same
time we could also just be talking about
nothing because maybe they were just
getting in the car together and there's
no story here so yeah who knows Honolulu
sums it up I only want them to date if
they are gonna get married
otherwise I don't need that incestuous
Ness yeah I don't need like the breakup
and then
the drama like I need love or nothing
right that's how we felt about Tristan
and Jordan let me first hurry about
we're like okay they have to be in love
and like it's the greatest love affair
of our time but no turns out it's just a
path now that we're like a few that's
his Josh Peck now that we're a few steps
out of Jordan and and we can look at the
Jordan interest and thing like can you
believe that all that happened and like
nothing now it's like I haven't heard
from Jordan like she's still like
working and now she's like a regular old
thirst monster just like everyone else
but she's virtually irrelevant mom she I
think as Jordan would she's more
relevant than ever like being an
Instagram influencer she's working
harder there than ever and she's getting
more jobs and numbers she hasn't been
like cancelled or anything but it's just
like the divide between her and the
Kardashians it's just I don't think
there's and like in the old episodes
they talk about Kylie's like when I
decide to forgive her and if and you
know when I if I decide to be her friend
again I don't think there's any if
anyone know and I think that's Kylie
probably thought her life without Jordan
would be so different and like really
like less and meaningful but I think she
found a way to fill the void like very
easily like leading into her family a
lot and her and stormy and her new
friends and her old friends and just
like including more people in her life
and I don't think that her life feels
less full without Jordan I think maybe
she thought that it what did she would
eventually forgive her because she
missed her yeah also it's just like
denial you just want to think it's like
not as big of a deal as it is but then
when you have some time you're like oh
yeah there's no coming back from that
yeah I'm like okay if Jordan doesn't
come back yeah so far so good I feel in
Ojai least thriving we're seeing more of
Kylie than ever and I feel like Jordan
was really hugging Kylie and now there's
enough Kylie to share with all of her
friends urease Stassi Sophia
if TIFF Victoria amber Arielle by the
way that's so true Jordan was hogging
Kylie and like from us to keeping her
all to herself
yeah and it wasn't fair it's not fair
like new to be a team player
you only get one Kylie in a generation
and like we deserve all as yes of her as
she can give to us do you remember when
we got a Kylie reality show and like
Jordan was a star and she ruined it yeah
I didn't even watch it no Kylie reality
show and I didn't watch it because was
all that Jordan and their anxiety
together yeah no I would watch now a
show about like my life of Kylie & Co
and and the whole crew of course I'm
watching someone like 50% when I'm
watching Jordan just as much as I'm
watching Kylie I'm like I don't know her
no I don't
her and look that somebody came here
well I like him but I like him - oh and
Tokyo style like it was cool but like
that's not what you want a Kylie a
reality show for you wanted for Thailand
it was a show like based around her
snapchat at the time which was like
those that was who she was hanging out
with but now it's just her network is so
much larger she's doing more interesting
things back then she didn't even drink
like you know there was a mom and now
she's like flying everyone on the Kylie
scan plane to Turks and Caicos like that
is something I would watch a video uh
this is a show for she should have a
show and then she could like expense
literally everything I call Kylie
cosmetics like Kylie ko yeah and it
would just be like about her business
and these sorts of influence like so
Cosmo
well that was supposed to be like a
reality show about the business but like
not interesting Kylie cosmetics
definitely interesting like I heard no
one's allowed to be on their phones in
the office and I watch that video what
you sent it to me sorry it was only an O
actually watch it weren't you told just
told me that's what she said yeah she
was definitely like what's the back
story worse she worked there she didn't
like say that she got hired as a temp
but based off of everything she was
saying those definitely what the role
was so like then when she was like oh
cuz her temporary mission was finished
she like made it a whole big thing
because she pretended like she had to
take one day off and they wouldn't let
her and like she tried to like make a
mocker like make them look bad but a
couple interesting tidbits is that you
literally cannot whip your phone out
like if you do like you will be escorted
out like because like if you take a
picture before my line or things like
that I can't really remember is
interesting in the sense of like you
learned like things Kylie doesn't come
to the office every day and she was like
and you knew when she did because I
could be any flowers in the in the
bathroom like you knew something was
happening um just like in tidbits like
that but like her whole mantra of the
story like that it was a bad place to
work for because she got fired because
couldn't take a day off when really she
was a temp didn't really land for me
like she was like I hate videos like
that of people who like review or just
like talk about something and they just
feel the need to say something necessary
I mean say something nasty like for no
reason like we were just talking about
how I've been spending so much time on
my YouTube app that I recently came
across just a random video that I
watched and it was a girl who is a
plus-sized youtuber reviewing skins oh
my god I'm so glad you're bringing this
up and as a plus-sized [ __ ] like you
know I was here for the review because
like I have the stuff and I wanted to
see what other people thought of it and
she was trying it on and she was just
like complaining about things like for
no reason
and I just felt like she was trying to
like make a mockery of skims because
like everyone makes fun of the
Kardashians and like she thought it was
like the cool thing to do when when in
reality schemes is actually like a great
brand like the super inclusive they go
up to 4x um and they're a new brand and
like they have their problems but like I
don't know I just thought like she was
looking for problems when there weren't
one like complaining that there was an
extra-large but not a one XL when for
the most part on one XL is an
extra-large yeah he had large extra
large 2 XL three XL 4 XL yeah large
extra large 2 X 1 X is Excel and she was
saying that Kim just skipped over a size
and they literally was like oh my god I
always thought 1 X was no I am actually
large yeah and I and I asked around cuz
then I was like for our merch are we
missing a side you did Jackie Jackie on
our team literally after you watch a
video and you were like by the weight we
have 1 X oh and we have one exhale it
worries that just Excel and they were
like that is Excel then you wrote back
to me you're like you skinny [ __ ] and I
always think like when I shop at forever
21 they're their sizes go small medium
large one XL there's no extra large
that's when I learned that an
extra-large really is a 1x oh yeah so I
just like hated that videos 1x an attack
sound right
XL e so that video really like just I
was like hating that whole thing where
it's like you just have to say something
nasty about the Kardashians because like
it's a popular thing to do you know yeah
I forgot how we got to this Angela some
people are saying that 1x is not Excel
ok I in themselves I like with sizing
people I am an XL and I'm telling you
that I am a 1x also of course I would
rather say I'm an XL than saying I'm a
1x I'll cuz like it sounds cuter but I
yeah it was the same they're saying that
XL is straight sizes and then 1 X is
plus size ok it's in the gym it's in a
different category for sure but
measurement wise it is the same it's
just one axis to it but like in a store
that doesn't sell plus-size you won't
find a 1x but you might find in Excel
yes but measurement wise it is the same
it's a branding thing ok got it
so I just thought that was like an
unfair argument you totally also people
I want to just go back to what you were
saying about that video about Kylie's
office people are like that's so Devil
Wears Prada when it's like any corporate
office that you work in like the CEO is
not there all the time and when they are
it's like open parade in town also when
the when the CEO is a celebrity it's
like even a bigger deal like even if
they're famous for being a CEO like Anna
Wintour she wasn't famous before that
but now she's
because she's a CEO of vogue
editor-in-chief or whatever
of course like there's gonna be a
chilling vibe no but and it's at any how
many when the CEO is there everyone sits
up a little straighter
it's like Kylie was walking into her
office and everyone was like just
slumming it ya know like sitting there
with their like sloppy untucked shirts
yeah Kylie Jenner took a shirt I'm tuck
your shirt in
totally okay next story another
Kardashian's story Kim kardashian-west
this was something that I saw on her
Instagram that I thought was so
interesting says that she has gained 18
pounds in the past year
sometimes we fall off so she was on her
Instagram story training with her
trainer and she said that she's about 18
pounds up from where she was at this
time last year so then of course I went
through her Instagram to see what was
this time last year that was when they
dressed as angels oh yeah Victoria's
Secret and she was so snatched but I
feel like she's smaller than ever right
there's no way she gained 18 pounds
there's a lot of that will probably
muscle because um that's true because
she's 14 ounce
so body by Mel yeah but she also was
saying it's her eating and I so relate
to her she was like I work out like fine
but when I eat like I just go off and I
that same same all right
did you watch Kardashian's last night
yes such a good episode except for the
teasing kamon thank you leaving it to
the end and saying to be continued - you
guys come on they made it seem like last
night's episode was the comodo
controversy and then we didn't get to
that we didn't even get to the launch
like we got nothing it said next week
next week which was really frustrating
but kind of interesting though that she
like sets up all these photo shoots her
sisters and did it go like that is weird
that was actually weird cuz it's like
you worked so hard on your businesses
like every day having meetings in your
house from 5:00 a.m. till probably like
there's so much you just the the things
that are outward-facing
the things are gonna lead to chance yeah
by the way I'm glad that she changed the
name from kimono to scams because a lot
of people found it offensive and I do
think skins is a better name but the
fact that we that we will never see that
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
infomercial mercial is devastating Lynch
posted on her Instagram like here's a
sneak peek of the infirmary launching
for scams as if it's coming out soon
maybe they had to redo it with the new
name but it's like it's so crazy how
really everything happens for a reason
because I'm sure when the kimono thing
was happening like to her it she had all
this inventory as we'll see you next
week which I thought was gonna be this
week and it's just like a huge blow for
the business but it really forced her to
be so much better in skins is like now
iconic name that that it's like Kleenex
Heinz
you know Spanx where it's like it's
household to the thing you're it's the
name of the thing and it's also the
thing like yeah we're getting skinnier
like yeah it's the Nate you know kimono
a kimono is a garment that is not
shapewear so it was just sort of like
gets your name it's just kinda caused
her to be better and now we have like a
better name and it's also like how
spanks was the name of the brand but now
anyone who wears shapewear more often
than not will refer to it as Spinks like
it became such a household name yeah but
I think that his skins being called skin
yeah I actually want to order more seams
cuz I loved last night I love the seams
that I haven't I love which he's been
wearing and I also want comfy skins I
want to be someone who wears like power
panties every day like I don't need to
wear Spanx every day with the shorts
notes things but um I want to wear like
control top panties every day like why
not look a little skinnier yeah you know
I wonder Sara Blakely is like shaking
you know I kind of think she might be
yeah like I'm sure she'll be fine and
she's a billionaire and like she's now
she doesn't even know I care like her
her fortune has been made but like do
you think the people at Spanx are like
Chuck I think it's a big it's a shake-up
for the shapewear industry for sure like
Kim card act like the right like the
woman who like could have been the face
of Spanx like if they had paid her and
she's like she would've been a perfect
you know person for it like yeah I just
think like the industry's quaking for
sure yeah
I or and if they're not they should be
and if they're not gonna they're gonna
get left behind
but that we can't wait maybe Kim saying
this thing that she gained 18 pounds is
like a strategic endorsement for scammy
yeah because at the end of the day like
someone's super skinny like making
shapewear like no I need someone with
like roles who knows how to make
shapewear so maybe she's like trying to
be more relatable because at the end of
the day like this isn't news you know oh
well I just think it's news that someone
who like diets and yo-yos like this is
interesting that she's 18 pounds morning
and you would never tell I thought it
was in the matrix games because it's
like oh I thought it was an endorsement
first games because she gained 18 pounds
but we can't even see if her skin said
she's wearing wait no no and maybe I
feel like now that I'm thinking that
we're talking about it like maybe she
said that like as a they like be a
little bit more relatable and be like
because and you would never know you
yeah but I don't think just because
she's so in shape but I don't think that
makes her like someone who's not
relatable when it comes to shaper cuz I
feel like she struggles she has
struggled in the past like we've seen
her and she's always just trying to be
more such you know yeah but in the last
like maybe two years like she is more
snatch than ever so it's like when she
was young like with the kids but because
she had a surrogate for the last two
kids like she's almost like a little she
has she has a super unattainable body so
these are since the beginning and it's
like she attained that body like a to me
she's always gonna be like a relatable
body image role model for me at least
not for me cuz we all know that she's
capable of not looking like that there's
so many people in models and some who
like they don't they could do whatever
they want yeah they might work out but
like they're gonna look what they look
like yeah yeah no I mean I guess she
works hard for for her body and she
looks great but there's something like
and I think what would I like about her
is that she's been open about like her
inability to stop eating like that's
relatable but at end of the day like her
body doesn't seem attainable to me like
one because it is so like not real
looking like with that ass and two it's
like she has a gym in her house like you
know what I mean ya know the ass thing
is something else yeah but I just feel
like she knows the struggle you know yes
no I feel like she knows the struggle by
the way I know that she knows the
struggle her wearing the dress to the
met there's no way she gained 80 pounds
that tiny piece of steel that condom
there's no way a lot of muscle in those
18 pounds but that was in May and now
we're in November like maybe she gained
nine pounds of muscle by the medon nine
pounds and also I did use the muscles a
lot yeah I don't think so this all
little thing just honestly sounds like a
lie I don't why would she lie to us no
one asked to sell skims I don't know I
just thought it was interesting it is
interesting but also probably lie okay
next up third story little Jenner news
Caitlyn Jenner is joining British
reality show for a 647 thousand dollar
payday Celebrity Big Brother I'm a
celebrity get me out of here oh my god I
forgot about that show member and
Spencer and Heidi we're on it hmm
Caitlyn Jenner just landed one of
reality televisions most lucrative deals
signing up to participate in popular
British series I'm a celebrity get me
out of here for over half a million
bucks the Sun reports the seven-year-old
will be flying to the show's location in
Australia next week after agree
to a 500,000 pound euro paycheck which
500,000 pounds I'm assuming 19 640 ya
know but that's not the pounds and euros
are separate paycheck equally roughly
equal to roughly six hundred forty seven
thousand US dollars wait that's so crazy
that Caitlyn Jenner needs six hundred
fifty thousand dollars like that's kind
of sad everyone needs six hundred fifty
thousand dollars
none of the Kardashians do they wouldn't
go on that show for six hundred thousand
dollars no because they're worth more
but like I feel I feel like she'll be
great honestly she's a reality TV
veteran it's just sad like she went from
being like really a trailblazer no she
went from being the greatest athlete of
all time
to being a trailblazer for transgender
youth to now being like almost like a
joke like this is sad like this is a sad
story I'm very upset well I'm glad she's
getting paid
well that's she does my bills to accept
that Spencer and Heidi in their heyday
they said they turned down a million
dollars to go back Wow
yeah even they didn't do it they did it
but they wouldn't go back yeah I know
you were gonna say Celebrity Big Brother
and that's like that's less sad there
are some cool people who go on it and I
guess somebody would whether you're like
in a bunk with the other campers and
counselors Mitch is there and the
Celebrity Big Brother house is actually
much nicer than the radio like it's for
celebrities but I'm a celebrity get me
out of here you're like in the
wilderness it's survivor style right
actually thinks she's very equipped yeah
I mean she wasn't an Olympic athlete she
definitely knows how to survive yeah but
there's just something there's something
sad about this like we were like you
can't report this story and not feel
like wow they might II they truly have
fallen yeah but it's like you girls
gotta eat
yeah you know it's gotta keep Sophia fed
right her girlfriend right
so I don't know I think I think she
might enjoy it
Oh apparently celebrity brother got
cancelled the shocking cuz like I would
have gone on it he was always making
news yeah like Jonathan Cheban was on it
I spoke to him he said it was like a
literally the most torturous time of his
life
who else Spencer and Heidi did actually
his name is food God now right sorry how
dare I um Spencer and Heidi Brandi
Glanville yes do they ever do it in
America
or it was always UK I don't know I have
not a big brother me neither but it's
like they have cultivars that following
a big brother yeah I respected you break
the hell out of it okay next story
really some crazy news Vicki Gunvalson
is suing Kellie Dodd for the con woman's
statement so this is interesting on a
number of levels but most Real
Housewives have gotten used to a little
trash talk on set Vicki Gunvalson isn't
going to take it anymore the veteran
cast member has filed a lawsuit against
co-star Kelly Dodd over three statements
she made on camera believing they may
have an effect on her personal and
business relationships if aired the
statement in question include quote you
prey on older people you are a con woman
and you engaged in fraud Gunvalson
exclaims she explained to Barbara
producers that all three of these
statements are false and could have
negative effects on her livelihood under
the pseudonym Jane row Vicki also
pointed out that she's never been sued
in thirty-one years of business and has
an A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau it's unclear if Bravo has plans
to air the scene during the 14th season
however they included the con woman line
in the show's new trailer this isn't the
first time she's been called a con woman
though right yeah also this is a very
thin argument as someone who has many
times thought about suing people for
defamation and libel I can tell you that
nine times out of ten nine point nine
times out of 99 out of a hundred times
like you you can't win
yeah and better she's certainly not
gonna win well then I think with this
lawsuit she's trying to deter Bravo from
airing these quotes because I mean it
hasn't happened yet
yes saying you prey on older people she
works in like the insurance industry oh
that's true you're a con woman you
engage in fraud I mean the cancer was
fraud was fraud and they kind and she
knew and she knew yeah I mean these
statements aren't well so in order to
win a defamation case you have to prove
that the statements aren't true the only
one that's we don't have you prey on old
people who you prey on old people that
could be untrue but like she would have
to prove that she didn't know and that's
what we've been trying to do for the
last three seasons is prove that she
didn't know no no she might prey on old
people in her business either no I'm
saying that she would have to prove that
all the statements are untrue so what
we've been trying to jail for the last
three seasons is how do you prove
herself that she didn't know that Brooks
was faking cancer I think she's just
trying to scare Bravo and I also thought
that house eyes can't sue each other I
just assumed that was part of their
contract because they never do yet maybe
because she's not a full-time housewife
anymore like she did that's interesting
and also what's so crazy is that like
this is crazy like if this was
in any other franchise like it would be
so but like something about the OSI
house I was like they're so sad like
Bevins a franchise like they really
can't get their [ __ ] together and this
should be elevating the season even more
like I genuinely don't care oh I don't
care about this specifically I kind of
like the tactic of Viki gonna try and
stop it from airing but this season is
great by the way that people have tried
this before remember Barbara Kay before
she was a housewife sued Bravo because
she got her audio got picked up on Tom's
mic being like saying something about
listen Aires will never like yeah and
she's so crazy that she ended up being a
housewife after that but she tried to
sue Bravo into not playing her audio
even though she was in you have to sign
a release like there's no way that they
weren't gonna air that yeah I forgot
about that it was written up in
paychecks very interesting article very
interesting so I I wonder what's gonna
happen nothing like they're gonna air it
no one's gonna get sued like this is
just this is like a threat that nobody
it's like what's it like an unveiled
threat ah it's a threat that has no
weight okay
it's like if you were I threat you know
yeah I am a threat I am a deadly deadly
threat but you it's like me knows listen
I'm skinny okay bit and final story not
reality TV not Kardashians interesante
nonetheless a little podcasting news and
the broadcasting news brought to you by
hell afresh oh I love hello fresh young
American camper started on hello fresh
because she loves it they make cooking
delicious meals at home a reality
regardless of your comfort in the
kitchen from step-by-step recipes to pre
measured ingredients you'll have
everything you need to get a WoW worthy
dinner on the table in just 30 minutes
say goodbye to endless grocery store
trips and takeout food hellofresh has
you covered you can make deliciousness
part of your week every week break out
of your dinner rut with hellofresh is 20
plus seasonal chef carry recipes each
week there's something for everyone from
family recipes to calorie smart and
vegetarian which I know is what you made
because you're a kosher [ __ ] I am a
kosher [ __ ] and I love that vegetarian
option and fun menu series like Hall of
Fame and craft burgers they have more
five-star recipes than any other meal
kits so you know you'll get something
delicious they're flexible and they fit
your lifestyle you can add extra meals
to your weekly
order as well as yummy add-ons like
garlic bread and cookie doubt YUM easily
change your delivery days food Hamas's
and skip skip a week if you need like
we're going to Morocco we're going to
see ma yeah November's gonna be a light
month for me but it's so great for a new
year's resolution you guys my new year's
resolution last year was to learn how to
cook and because of hella friend because
of hellofresh
I learned how to cook and I was able to
actually implement what I learned wow I
guess we've been working with hellofresh
for almost a year because we were
talking about in January how that was
your resolution and you just got started
with hellofresh
yeah no and you can make your dreams
come true at Grand prospect Hall if
you're not a New Yorker you do that but
if you are you're welcome anytime only
get nine free meals with hellofresh go
to hellofresh comm slash toast nine and
enter the code tous nine so that's
hellofresh comm slash toast and the
number nine and then enter the code
toast
number nine Toa st nine and you'll get
nine meals free Wow good stuff really
hello fresh is amazing it makes cooking
so easy comfortable even though I
learned how to cook like it is a
daunting task and they have the
pre-measured in green so you don't have
to go buy a whole onion like they'll
send you how much chopped onions you
need cuz it's like okay you buy a whole
onion you cry and you chop it what do
you do with the rest of it you look put
in tin foil yeah and I guess if you're
someone who cooks the next night to
you'll use it again but like if cooking
was like your one big writing you know
then you have all of these half it is so
wasteful
it's really wasteful and so I really do
I love Hello freshen and so does
American camper because she's getting
home-cooked meals every night and her
mom doesn't have to make from scratch
the best nor does her counselor okay
Vinny the final story fresh response
rate the fit the final story I think
you're gonna be really interested about
it because it's podcasting new celebrity
podcasting news
Kate Hudson announces new podcast with
her brother Oliver Hudson called sibling
rivalry revelry wait I'm shook okay I
know you were ready to yeah he's ready
to roll my eyes cuz it's like okay we
need another skinny blonde woman like
telling us what juices to drink but
Oliver Hudson is a premium addition he
is hysterical they have our great
sibling banter I actually think this
will be great I think this will be great
because I do love Kate Hudson and I'm
not saying anything bad about her but
she's like someone relatable like with
her like you know her lifestyle but when
she is on Instagram like going back and
forth with her brother
like it is super funny like that's what
real people do and like Oliver Hudson is
just a precious like a precious gem of a
man I think he's so underrated he's so
funny I think he's a perfect because
he's so funny on Instagram but it's like
hard to follow people who are like on
inserting you have to watch other
stories I think he's a perfect person
for podcasting yeah and then like Kate
brings the glamour he brings the funny
Kate brings the audience but also like
Oliver Hudson's interesting because he's
one of those people who's like so funny
and got really even more famous because
of his Instagram but he's an actor so
it's like he can be himself when he's
acting when like that's what we came we
came here to see because we love your
Instagram yes exactly um but the podcast
launched today it's called sibling
sibling rivalry it explores the sibling
bond family dynamics the human mind body
and so much more I mean the podcast
available on toast news on the podcast
they'll interview other siblings as well
as people they're fascinated by oh my
god maybe in like the 400th episode when
it's like really dire and everyone is
away I mean out of every celebrity in
Hollywood sidling they've made it
abcdefg list and now they're ready to go
on to the h list with maybe they will
have us on jerk celebrities you say
buddies
it could be us yes yes yeah that
actually is quite attainable like we're
podcasters maybe like you know their
numbers aren't where they they're they
want to be they want to dive into like a
real podcast we're true podcasters yeah
yeah but this trend of like celebrity is
going into podcasting really makes me
mad and really speaking I'm not here for
it like Conan O'Brien being on the cover
I will never forget that like being on
the cover of Variety magazine is someone
who's breaking through this new platform
called possibly casting like hi I've
ever met Joe Rogan like there's so many
people on that [ __ ] and now it's like
those two girls from the office starting
to podcast jealous ladies yeah and it's
like they're all over our comedy chart
like it's so annoying like get out
there's give me two podcasts tours have
we said that before anything so
celebrity guest charts celebrity and non
celebrity
it's really annoying like I don't know
but I think for a celebrity like I mean
as a non-celebrity we look at somebody
some are like it's so annoying like get
out of our space you and your millions
of fans like you're ruining it for the
rest of us but I think for them it's
like there's so much pressure cuz it's
like definitely if you go from like
movies and TV to podcasting it's a step
down and now you have to maintain that
audience and you have to be number one
on the charts or else it's [ __ ]
humiliate okay wait that also really
revised we have something that we
haven't discussed here
bass starting the very first morning
live social show shut the [ __ ] up
I didn't even get [ __ ] promoting it
as the first ever I'm like excuse me
honey how are ya like he keeps it the
first the first it's like a pot and it's
like and we're the first live show in
the morning to talk about pop culture
like a podcast yes I think and it's also
live okay well I will say um obviously
not so major I never even heard of it
and like I in pop culture
nobody even tag me in it and I get
tagged in everything no I got tagged in
it so I get types of how many [ __ ]
giveaways you guys like I know my god I
don't like that does it say tag your
favorite influence had three friends and
it's like I don't know you guys please
stop doing that because I always click
it and I'm just feel like it more on and
also on Claude with no job when people
are really trying to get me to see
something they'll tag me in like
pertinent things and actually love
logging into quad with no job because I
get tagged in like funny like friends
things like things I want to see and now
being cluttered with Louis Vuitton
giveaways no oh at least it's Louie time
for you me it's like drunk elephant oh
by the way there was trauma with drunk
elephant did you see no I couldn't
remember it or like I don't want to
speak on it but I saw there was some
drama like with their formulas or
something oh whatever
anyways I'm always getting tagged in
like some free beanie giveaway please
love and like a hack in the hacky sack
you know please stop a few things that I
just wanted to UM speak on about this
but I'm now forgetting everything that I
was thinking about oh you posted
something yesterday that we have to talk
about which was very the marine who was
on Jesse Watters talking about his
service animal which was so beautiful
but he's actually like an Instagram
famous Navy SEAL my favorite kind of
name and I just learned he actually he's
a like a canine specialist for like
military dogs and he trained Thiago
Erica Chan's dog that's how she knows
him and which is how he figured out who
he was but he went on Fox News and like
did a second waters and he was like hi
they were like wrapping up and he was a
kind to say one more thing and he liked
me about the dogs and was like and also
Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself and
it was so funny the video went viral he
has gotten like so many Instagram
followers from it it's [ __ ]
hysterical you guys it's incredible it's
like the whole world can agree on this
one thing he uses platforms so perfectly
and like he's such a respectable kind of
guy this was talking Navy said I'll
generated officer everything wait
the end of the video I thought his dog
was obviously gonna bite his arm off or
something I thought that's funny I
thought the dog was gonna do something
silly like what its tongue out you know
I'm like why am I watching this no same
is you guys it's incredible and just
like things like that don't happen every
day and when they it's on my Instagram
check it out when they do you have to
you have to applaud them and by the way
I've been looking at your Rogen's
Instagram and he has been posting like
such hilarious memes it's like that
pregnancy that thing you sent me like
the pregnancy tests like Joburg Ivan
Jeffrey up see didn't kill himself like
it's so funny I'm just like living for
this actually a toaster very interesting
Wow I forgot to say this lives in Palm
Beach or some area in Florida
I'm drove past Jeffery up scenes like
old house and there is a van sitting
outside with tinted windows it's a
little late for that don't you think
yeah maybe they're just getting rid of
evidence
maybe but like he's got what if I don't
know cuisine was in my dream she's a
weird one okay can we talk about the
Real Housewives of Atlanta I know you
don't want to let me just play it out
for you sure Kenya Moore is back Kenny
Moore is back okay she had a baby we see
each other we see each other so the show
thank God Kenya Moore is back okay I
feel a little if you got it let me tell
you why but I really like her and I
think she's she's made for television
for them to take her off of television
which was made for everyone's life like
the show has really changed because now
in the offseason both Kenya and Porsha
had babies
II was pregnant so it's like really like
a different show now it's very family
focused like they had a kids party this
week but they open the episode showing
motherhood for the two for the two girls
and Kenya wakes up in a dress full
makeup talking about how her baby never
cries and she's an angel
and her house was so clean you know and
it was like who is she kidding like it
was just like so fake and then they cut
to Porsha who her fiance like there was
this huge blog post written about him
how he was like sleeping with everyone
in Atlanta they were accusing him of
bestiality like and so she's in such a
dark place because she left him and
she's a new mom her house is a mess
she's not wearing makeup her hair like
it's like real it's it's yeah yeah yeah
I don't have any specifics no and
they're just like circling the drain on
all these rumors and it's so crazy
because the rumor all started with his
youtuber who made a video about it and
this girl's getting so much [ __ ]
press they keep playing her video on
Atlanta oh my god so but what's really
sad is like they they cut it so
motherhood is hard enough like for
anyone
now her fiance is like not really in the
picture she's super depressed like she
can't leave the house like I think she
definitely has some some sort of
postpartum and there's like playing
these two clips next to each other and
like Kenya's being so like fake about it
and poor she was like really letting
everyone in like it was actually making
me really sad she's like sitting on the
couch thank God for her mom and sister
her mom like basically lives in the
house with her and like does everything
and helps out and the sister comes over
every day like it's it's actually so sad
like she can't stop crying she's I don't
want to leave the house she's like every
day I get ready to leave the house and
it's an hour two hours three hours and
then it's six o'clock and I don't wanna
go out anymore like it's really sad and
she's making me really sad and then
Kenya's over here just being like so
[ __ ] fake like I can't and [ __ ] oh my
husband yeah she has a husband now and
he lives in here didn't they just get
divorced yes but he lives in New York
and it's all so weird and there's a lot
of rumors that you pay them to be her
husband like it's so incredibly odd and
the Kenya is just like she's not being
authentic I'm like when you're on the
show all these ladies like they put
their lives out and like she's just like
in her fake house in her model home
where there's no furniture and there's
no dirt and the baby's just perfect and
it's like that's not how it's like and
it just really bothered me and I think
that's why they they juxtaposed it so
well and I got the message I got it it's
clear Porsha is still working like she
does that show right yes so she was on
maternity leave and she was talking
about it she has to go back in a month
and she's like yeah because she's only
the kid it's like it's a lot for her
like that's [ __ ] real motherhood like
I just I felt like she was being so open
and honest like she didn't have to be in
Kenya was just said really hiding behind
like the show I didn't like it
but then they all get out of bed and
they go to Kenya's baby's first birthday
which was so extra Kenya's finances
confused the [ __ ] out of me she had like
it was at the pink hotel it was Barbie
themed you would have loved it like
everyone the kid had a babysitter like
it was just like her finances make no
goddamn sense I mean everyone had to
dress up as Barbie and this is where the
lowest thing happens okay so Cynthia
Bailey who it's another season and her
whole storyline it's about a man like
she's so uninteresting like I actually
haven't started to really just like her
and she's hitting that guy Mike Hill who
is so cute and he's a sportscaster and
they and member we met him at um
Access Hollywood but he looked so
familiar here in LA before yes yes
yeah I'm so familiar and then he was
talking about how he loves her so much
and he's gonna propose to her and they
did end up getting engaged but at this
point he's not engaged and she's just
thirsting so hard to get engaged like to
the point it's so losery and desperate
that she's talking about it she's
putting pictures of wedding dresses in
her [ __ ] Instagram story then they
to dress up as Barbie wait she comes up
to the party as Bridal Barbie right
bouquet she has a little flower girl
like it's so loser II I could die and
she's trying to own it being like yeah
I'm being thirsty like so that people
like won't say it about her but the
whole thing is so weird and so loser
even like it's I'm really not liking her
I she in such a rush to get married even
like him like she was just she just got
out of a marriage that she shouldn't
have entered into right now and it's
like her kids are grown like she is a
lovely life I think that like she wants
to get married so she'll have a
storyline she has nothing going on but
she's like Kenya's ass-kisser it's so
annoying so then before the party a
bunch of the ladies are at OLG which is
Kandi's restaurant and this girl comes
over her name is sincerely since airily
they were saying but sincerely and she
comes over and she's like hey Candi I
just wanna introduce myself I'm
sincerely like I'm the one that
everyone's saying is sleeping with
tennis Porsha's fiance and she's like I
just wanna let you know like I've never
met him and like I feel so bad and like
I don't know how to reach out but like I
don't want to be responsible for like
ruining a beautiful black family so like
I just wanted to come over here and tell
you so they have this information which
is good news you know yeah and they're
being so dramatically do Tyler the last
time if you don't want to hear it like
of course you would want to hear this
every no stupid so at the party they
tell Kenya and Kenny's like I'm gonna
tell her you know Gabe's good [ __ ]
news so Kenya and Porsha I've had this
very toxic relationship like for years
remember with the bullhorn at the
Reunion and she pulled her hair yeah so
now it's like they both have new babies
and they're like really
um connecting and connecting and like
they're sitting at and they're they took
a minute to like nurse I and they're
sitting and in different room at the
party and they're like this beautiful
friendship is boss me and Kenny is like
I just wanna tell you like the girls
just told me like sincerely showed up at
OLG and said that she'd never met her
never met Dennis in her entire life and
it was like good news but then it
started drama like why did can you tell
it was so stupid when at the end of the
day like it was good news it shouldn't
have been drama started so is there a
possibility that he's not all of those
things well is there no possibility that
he's not engaging in bestiality well the
bestiality we're not sure about but they
in the previews for the next couple
episodes they show them in therapy and
he admits that he cheated okay
so there's some validity to that video
but good that bloggers forgetting her
she ass on Bravo yeah [ __ ] we have yet
to do that we don't try hard enough yeah
so it's act oh and then oh sorry Nene
wasn't on the whole episode because
she's on the outs with absolutely
everyone because she was so [ __ ]
crazy at the last week
and it's really hard for me because I
stand Roz Washington you know that I
starts watching Tim I know so she's so
unreasonable she was like you know
Teresa maybe that's why I never got back
into Atlanta because it's like I [ __ ]
love Nene I can't watch anything that's
gonna make me unloved her no I just want
to go out on this high hell outside
outside of Atlanta and she left member
she move to LA and she had the girls
come over they couldn't get up the hill
in the limo like it was just like she
thought she was too good for it and then
she got humbled and now I think she's
like mad at the world and also she's in
such a tough spot with Gregg's illness
like she was just being them around um
in Jersey the season like at the Reunion
Teresa was just being like so
unreasonable because she's like the star
of the show
yeah that's Nene and she's being so
unreasonable and so rude and so petty
and he's like I I only want to love her
you know I I know and it's really
difficult so she wasn't on this episode
because there's no reason she would have
been out to dinner with anyone there's
no reason she would have been invited to
the birthday party like she's on the
outs with absolutely everyone um so I
don't even know why she's a housewife
this season and in the promo they put
her all the way at the end where she's
literally been in the middle almost
every single season so she's obviously
very upset and I follow her on Twitter
and she was retweeting every single
person it was like where's Nene the show
isn't good without her like she's
obviously like pressed as hell um so I
don't know when she makes an appearance
but she does because she's in the the
previews but she's almost now borderline
like friend of housewife you know that's
crazy yeah it's gonna be really good
season wow that actually sounds really
good no you're enticing me it's great
and they they are just like so
themselves like Atlanta really is this
like tight-knit community where they
have like their own culture like their
own like its way of speaking and like I
find myself talking like that is
impressive yeah I know and that's what
bgs called us they said we're pres
it's really good you guys and I just
can't believe we have four franchises on
this week I'm going into overload we're
so blessed I just want to talk about
Kardashian's quickly in the Murad run
but it's very good club we going a
problem was the strangest thing I've
ever seen by the way because why
couldn't you bring a friend what wait
and we followed it along on social media
it was like such a cute thing that she
was doing she was like so excited to be
there when in reality like that car ride
gave me a pit like I missed the whole
thing was so weird like why did she rent
a limo and like she got [ __ ] up and
had to go home like it was so weird it
was so weird then Kim Kim oh no I love
that they're really showing us
everything though them referring to it
as kimono because I actually had
forgotten and I think they could
probably couldn't glazed over it and
said like we didn't film yeah um but
they went to all of these efforts and
like all these and it's funny the way
that it launched it was like such as
ships
shapewear line maybe because after like
the backlash they didn't want to be
joking about it right with the with the
film of Chloe dancing to baby charged
infomercial etc but the sister they're
just like great sisters don't show up
for one another yeah I love how like
North decides where they're going on
vacation oh my god
so funny also so cute when she was like
when I'm big I wanna move closer that's
that's American camper that's so
something just a child says North is
American camper bouncing interesting
like who goes trips you know like
Courtney obviously was down to go
because she doesn't really work
no and the kids like it just actually
makes a lot of sense yeah but it's like
everyone has kids now like but did not
as met it was so little that she doesn't
mean like she's not on she doesn't go to
school so she doesn't have break you
know um
and same with stormy so we've got the
three the oldest kids and the oldest
kids yeah Kanye was there allegedly but
I did not see him we saw him at the
dinner table I did see him I saw him um
what else happened Chris oh the OJ of it
all that was actually crazy and I love
that she sued them yeah the whole thing
was really looks sad really sad really
crazy yeah the morally corrupt Faye
Resnick why is she morally corrupt by
the way who called her that Camille and
it seemed like she was calling her that
in reference to the trials because she
didn't really know her or maybe like
that was like a headline like a famous
maybe that seems like a camille Grammer
statement yeah also if we learned
anything about coming like this season
is that she's definitely not like the
first couple seasons were like she's
crazy and then she came back I'm like oh
she got a bad at it no she really showed
her true colors she's not done I don't
believe everything she says she's very
pretentious yeah but like what did
favorites president just took the stand
in like friend who was murdered right hi
grace the whole thing was so crazy like
they were this that group of friends and
then like one of them was murdered right
and it was on them to like to fend her
and like testify or defend they could
just split the group right and I'm sure
it was the popular thing to defend and
like take okay sigh yeah but that's why
I like as much as everyone thinks like
both Faye Resnick and Kris Jenner are
like evil like Hollywood monsters like
at end of the day they did the right
thing when the going got rough and I
respect them for that I hate gray and
justice for Ron Goldman
justice for Ron Goldman I just will
never be served from no never because
like we only talked about the two of
them when he was the innocent bystander
right like hey this had nothing to do
with him in there there he goes just
getting murdered yeah just for like
returning a pair of son
right no good deed no good deed and like
if you ever leave your sunglasses
somewhere just forget about them yeah no
actually I left an amazing pair of
sunglasses at 40 karats like my favorite
restaurant and I mean I'm there every
day so I didn't like when I was home I
was like should I go back I might not
probably be there for tomorrow and I
went back like two days later and they
were gone like someone stole them
sunglasses are mean to be lost so when
you're buying a pair just know am i okay
with losing me and they gave me like the
lost-and-found bag with like a bunch of
tacky cheap so gladsome like where are
my sunglasses these are some ones still
the good ones yeah of course like thick
and heavy glasses
anyways justice for Ron Goldman is a
great way to end this episode um thank
you all for tuning in to the morning
toast the Millennium morning show would
you like to try it well I actually want
to take something up with you and I
guess we'll do it on the air it's
actually redundant and unnecessary to do
that whole thing at the end of the show
because if someone's listening to that
they know what the show is they just got
through the episode you know but like if
someone's listening on YouTube they
might not know it's a podcast and if
someone's listening on podcast they
might not know that be live stream on
YouTube right but we got them here and
like now that they're here maybe we
should tell them like they're ready
doing the thing that we need them to do
like let's just have them like follow me
on Instagram or something thank you so
much for listening to the morning shows
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so feel free to
give this video a thumbs up I send it to
your friend send it to your friends and
subscribe leave a comment and what it's
like so many people watch we don't get
the subscribers subscribe we're taking a
lot of pride in our new thumbnails
subscribe you guys we're putting a lot
of effort into our youtube channel
subscribe please please send it to a
friend who you think would enjoy this
episode or who's having a slow day at
work or who just need to smile put on
her face by too fast talking Millennials
who aren't afraid to Amaris themselves
on the internet we're also available as
a podcast anywhere podcast can be found
so that's itunes spotify stitcher it's
at the morning shows feel free to leave
a comment subscribe review and then also
send it to your friend mom and grandpa
who lets pop culture because that's what
we do thank you so much people don't
like favor Isaac because she wrote a
book okay but everyone wrote a book
except the judge no I think he might
have written about November at the end
of judge Ito
yeah at the very end of the series that
Ryan Murphy did they did side by sides
of all the characters who got played and
all the people that they were a book so
then at the end it said almost every
single person no actually every single
person involved in this trial wrote a
book except judge ear oh okay good well
hey roudabeh I'm sorry I don't try her
for writing a book homegirls got to eat
okay totally she just lost her French to
go through her time she's got eat she's
just you know
I don't care yeah love you guys have a
great day we'll see you tomorrow
you